what we consider real art is a movie
that does not have a safety net
godfather one did not have a safety net
godfather two did not have a safety net
apocalypse now did not have a safety net
it was made on its own terms it didn't
also have a few dozen car crashes and
whatever the formula is that is the
safety net
[Music]
the godfather
well it's sort of astonishment that 50
years have gone by a lot of these
memories are still pretty vivid in my
mind i was about 29 when i began
preparing the godfather and in the
course of the years involved in making
it and editing it i guess i was in my
very early 30s nothing about what my
life was like remained the same after
the godfather and certainly that film
changed everything for me
but let's be frank
you never wanted my friendship
and uh
you were afraid to be in my dad
i didn't want to get into trouble
i understand i could easily be described
as penniless
before i made the film my father was a
musician so my childhood was pretty much
raised in the shadow of my father's
career and we all wanted him to get his
big break my brother
wanted to be a novelist and and i wanted
to be the junior version of whatever my
brother was so all this
ultimately leads to me getting involved
in theater and then from theater i
became involved as a ucla film student
partly because my brother had gone to
ucla ultimately nothing was to prepare
to the experience of the godfather
number one it was a terrible experience
i was
always on the verge of about to get
fired and
a lot of my choices
were immediately discarded i wanted al
pacino to play the character michael and
they said that's ridiculous no one's
ever heard of him and i wanted marlon
brando to be the now famous don corleone
and they said oh he's a lot of trouble
and no one's going to see his films
anymore i wanted to make it in new york
they said you can't make it in new york
it's too expensive i wanted to make it
set in 1945 the way the book was they
said it's ridiculous you can't do it you
can't have it you can't do it and this
then
this is a terrible movie to the point
we're at at least four occasions i came
that close to getting fired
and then surprise was surprised it turns
out to be this gigantic
success and suddenly i became this
famous person which in itself is also
another thing to deal with so i have to
say to you that the 50 years ago having
made the godfather definitely changed my
life in many many ways for the better
but certainly in many also confusing
ways in terms of my relationship with my
idol who was my brother and my father
who i did have the pleasure of standing
next to when he won an oscar for the
second godfather that was a real thrill
so all i can say to you is it was
interesting
and i refused to be a fool
[Music]
dancing on the string held by all those
big shots
[Music]
i don't apologize that's my life but i
thought that
[Music]
but when it was your time that
the jew would be the one to hold the
strings in school i had learned the
technique of sort of outwitting the
faculty it was the faculty controlled
everything in
theater school they got a kick out of my
being rebellious and my competition with
them and controlling my the productions
i did in school but that was where i
learned
how to deal with the studios and trying
to figure out how even with no power
which a young filmmaker has zero power
that i could still through bluff and
misdirection and to get my way and i
guess that's how i got my way in the
godfather and got pacino to be in it and
got the look i wanted it was more
expensive to make the godfather as a
period picture than what they had wanted
which was to make it be set in 1973
which is when it was being made but i
credit those
victories
not to any i certainly had no clout but
i had a certain degree of skill
in outwitting
the people supervising you
and the tremendous talent of the people
i was working with on the godfather
photographer gordon willis the
production designer dean davaleris the
costume designer johnny johnson and that
extraordinary cast al pacino jimmy khan
robert duvall johnny casale al la terry
marlon brando
diane keaton on and on and not to
mention the writer mario puzo who had
written the story in the characters with
such people to work with is the only way
you can explain
the godfather that we now know as a
classic
but if clemenza can figure a way
to have a weapon planted there for me
then i'll kill them both
i didn't know
anything about what we call the mafia or
kosonostra but neither did mario know
anything about it he did everything by
research he read the velocity papers and
of course a lot has been written about
the story of the italian gangster in new
york the so-called five families and
what happened so my feeling was that
even though i knew nothing about i had
never met a real mafioso my family were
all musicians or tool and die makers but
one thing we were we were an italian
american family so
the home what we had at the dinner table
the way the
men related to the women the way the
children were at the wedding running
around the same with the fact that
italian weddings were sandwiches thrown
wrapped in paper and all of those
traditions and and sensibilities were in
my blood because i was an italian
american kid raised in in new york at a
time when it wasn't even cool to be an
italian my feeling
was that i could give the movie
authenticity about how italian americans
live i couldn't give them any other
authenticity but i did work very hard to
study and
try to take out of the novel uh what i
thought was in there which was despite
all of the pot boiler stuff there was in
there sort of the latent idea of a
classical almost experienced story about
a great king who had three sons that
needed to choose one to succeed him so i
think it was that political analysis
and story of
power and its succession that made the
film
more weighty and more interesting
the godfather part two
when the time came
for there to be a second godfather they
wanted a second father i thought it was
an absurd idea the godfather was
complete after the godfather i knew how
to make that type of italian-american
gangster film but i didn't want to do it
again i wanted to do something because
if you make films you don't know how to
make you learn a lot if you make films
you you you do know how to make you
maybe will make more money but you
basically don't learn as much so i was
more curious on going on into different
forms and make more movies i didn't know
how to make which is certainly was
apocalypse now and all the others they
basically wanted me to make another
godfather because they had been so
successful and finally they made me an
offer i couldn't refuse
after i i did try to say i'll write it
and i'll supervise it but i want to pick
a new young director to direct it and
had one in mind and they just said no
absolutely not we wouldn't trust this to
some new young guy which they had
trusted it to me so that didn't make any
sense but eventually when they said that
i could do anything i want and i
wouldn't have to kowtow to their
structure and and have them read my
script and give me their notes which i
said i wouldn't do and could call the
movie the godfather part two which was
there was more pushback on the title and
all than even the ridiculous amount of
money i asked them for which they didn't
seem to care but they rejected the idea
as a title saying people would think it
was the second half of the movie they'd
already seen i said well that was it i
would do it or i wouldn't do it
and that brought a whole
eternity of part twos and part threes
and part fours which i if i had known
that would happen i wouldn't have done
it any rate i got to make that and i
just used the story that i was
interested in
[Music]
you know you can always understand the
son by the story of his father and you
take rupert murdoch he was a kid in
australia whose father ran a big
newspaper and used to take his son to
see it or ted turner was
involved with a father that was a
basically a salesman of billboard ads
and out of his interest in his father he
went on so the story of the father is
always embedded in the son if you're
interested in the subject you read one
of the earliest persian books called
shanahama
the story of kings and it's all about
the fathers and the sons of the first
kings of persia and the son never
betrays the father the father always
betrays the son
i'll do business with you but the fact
is that
i despise your masquerade
the dishonest way you pose yourself
yourself and your whole [ __ ] family
senator
we're both part of the same hypocrisy
but never think it applies to my family
godfather two
when you think about it was a much more
complex picture than certainly the first
god godfather many other pictures i've
made i mean it had a part in las vegas
it had a party in lake tahoe it had a
part in old new york in the 20s it had a
part in sicily it had a party in cuba
all these places and yet the production
went smooth as it could be and and
people who say that i can only make
movies when i'm basically suffering and
under the ground godfather part two was
not suffering and was not under the gun
so to me that that demonstrates that
being scared out of your mind is not a
necessary element to make a good picture
you know subsequently other movies i
made that i didn't know how to make i
came to learn how to make them in the
course of doing it which is how i
is my peculiar approach to cinema i like
to learn by not knowing
how to hell to do it and then i
i'm forced to discover how to do it and
with the great
and most able collaborators which i've
always had because i have
had the good taste to choose colleagues
who are so extraordinary as vittorio
storaro and dean cavallaros and these
wonderful actors who have been involved
and the great marlon brando i mean he
was not just a great actor he certainly
was a great actor a very unique
kind of actor and he talked to him in
very different terms you'd never talk to
him about acting but he was also a great
man the way he thought about life about
termites about people about ants about
reality i mean he he was aside from his
acting a kind of a genius i'm old enough
now to say that i have met half dozen
geniuses i met akira kurosawa i met
federico fellini only but but brando was
extraordinary man possibly number one on
a list of geniuses i've had to honor and
and privileged to meet you always hear
these interesting stories about him and
being difficult to work with
he wasn't difficult to work with he just
worked a different way
you didn't talk to him about acting or i
think your motivation blah blah you
didn't talk about that in fact you
didn't even have to talk to him you
could just put the put a prop in his
hand and he would then use that prop to
accomplish what you really wanted
[Music]
apocalypse now
[Music]
as i would have expected i had no idea
how to make this kind of film and
because of that i had to learn on the
job pretty fast you know making a movie
is like running on a railroad track away
from a locomotive coming at you you
cannot trip
you cannot fall you're dead you have to
understand i made apocalypse now right
after i had won five oscars
and was probably one of the hottest
young if not the hottest young director
in hollywood
and absolutely nobody wanted to be in
apocalypse now and nobody wanted to have
anything to do with it so
i own apocalypse now for one simple
reason nobody else wanted it so i
undertook making apocalypse now by
basically agreeing to guaranteeing its
cost which was stupid because making a
film like that involves coordinating a
lot of elements
four or five languages were spoken we
were in the philippines we had many
scenes involving helicopters flying
around and we were in the helicopter
street that was in fake it wasn't cg
helicopters it was real clearly we did
not know what we were really doing i
didn't i was learning
as i was going and interest was at 27
you think now they're going to talk
about making interest you know your
mortgage might be a fourth percent or
five percent 27 percent on a dollar
which was rapidly building up as we were
going over budget all was on my shoulder
i had gone from the frying pan into the
fire i mean godfather
was a tough shoot because they didn't
like what i was doing and i had no power
apocalypse now was a very tough shoot
for a whole bunch of other reasons that
were out of my control and
i had my wife there and
you have that documentary because i've
always had a rule that if i'm going away
for more than uh 10 days on the movie i
would take my kids out of school because
i like my kids i want them to be around
i want to see them and also i want my
wife there but i had to do something
that would be interesting to her she
just doesn't want to go off and
be you know quote the wife so i put a
camera in her hand she's a very talented
handhold
operator and and being my wife when i
would come home after the day and say oh
this movie is a nightmare this is the
i'm going to get a f for this but this
is the worst movie ever made i was
hoping she would say oh no dear it's
gonna be okay you're gonna make a great
film instead she would say would you say
that again and put the microphone on i
don't like going to school you finish
your term paper
and maybe you get a b instead of an a
plus that you wanted so you get a b
but i'm going to get an f
this film is a 20 million disaster why
won't anyone believe me
i'm thinking of shooting myself all of
this nightmare
of
not knowing what i was doing being
against outrageous dogs having changed
the style of the movie making it as we
went along more surrealistic
you know movies are made by many many
things and people but one of the things
that make a movie is the movie
it contributes to making itself how does
that work well if you're throwing smoke
grenades and you and the photographer
and art director say gee that looks good
let's do more of that that's what i mean
by the movie starts nudging into you and
saying well don't go this way go more
this way so apocalypse now was sort of
telling us to make the film be more
surrealistic that the journey up the
river wasn't just a journey up the river
towards cambodia that the journey was a
journey through time and we were going
through time and we would end up in the
50s when the french were there
and then we would end up a thousand
years before that when the earliest
homo sapiens were there in their most
original form which was these montanard
natives who were the ifakao people of
philippines when the movie starts taking
over and making it when brando arrived
he looked at me so smart and he said huh
he said you painted yourself in a corner
didn't you meaning you had made this
movie
so surreal
that a normal big movie war scene ending
where the other guys come and they fight
isn't gonna work if you've made the
movie go in a very surreal direction
you're gonna have to think of a
resolution that is surreal or that can
at least have resonance
without just being a typical while the
army comes there was a big battle and
it's exciting battle and then it's over
so there i was having done this on the
hook for it and i won't even talk about
other calamities such as the typhoon
destroying all the sets or even a more
human
scare which was
marty sheen's heart attack which you
know one thing about marty sheen is
of course no doubt his family loved him
dearly but everyone loved him he was
just
an extremely nice person that uh
everyone was scared adina had not
survived the people who were making the
film would have closed down
and the money would have come from me
for what had been spent and i could
never get it back because i'd have no
finished film so when i told everybody
don't gossip don't call home and say
marty's had a heart attack because i
even am embarrassed with what i said my
wife's film although i had the power to
take it out i didn't but that was
i had to if marty dies
i want to hear that everything's okay
until i say marty is dead you got it if
it's not done man ship the whole office
out of here the film only even managed
to survive is because his wife
courageously just took him
to a hospital and didn't say he's out of
the picture
and because of that i kept shooting with
his brother
and then eventually thank god he came
back and was able to finish and he's
alive to this day as we know many people
said gee that movie is incredible but i
saw the rushes and there's unbelievable
stuff that never got in the picture so
i was encouraged to make a film version
called redux
which was like another god knows what 40
minutes longer and it was successful but
the problem is is that i felt well maybe
it's true the first apocalypse now were
left out a couple of important things
like the french plantation but
redux version it had too much put back
in it so you know i said you know it's
sort of like goldilocks and the three
bears this one was too much and this one
was too little so i tried to make a
balance which is called final cut that
still has the drive and the dynamics of
the first one
but keeps a version of the french
because that was an interesting comment
made that before there had been
americans at the vietnamese war it was a
french war
the conversation
i don't know what i'm gonna get him for
christmas yet he's already got
everything he doesn't need anything
anymore
well
i haven't decided what i'm going to get
you yet
i had loved the movie of antonioni blow
up i just thought i want to make a movie
like that that's the kind of movie i
want to make because it was intriguing
and it was moving and it was mysterious
and i was talking to a wonderful
filmmaker named irvin kirchner about
that and i said you know i wonder if
nowadays you know they can eavesdrop on
you with these little shotgun
microphones where they can bounce light
off the window pane and they can figure
out what was being said inside and he
said yeah that's true so i began to
learn and i was also interested in this
idea that you make a movie in which
repetition was an element in other words
the same thing was being said over and
over but every time you heard it it
meant something a little different and i
was interested in experimenting with
that
he'd kill us if he got the chance
always felt that sound is half the
experience that sound and picture are
the two components 50 50
that contribute to the effect on
audience the the interesting thing we
knew was sound was much cheaper
than picture so in the early days of
zoetrope
we put all our energy into sound and in
many ways created the modern soundtrack
format which now dominates the world
that was all done in san francisco
because zoetrope was here george was
here meaning walter mirch was here and
his colleagues but also dolby was here
and through that
friendly collaboration between us
and dolby
came a standard that then got
proliferated around the world it was
always appealing when a character is
hoist on his own pitard in other words
harry's punishment for his sins be they
real sins or not
is that he becomes obsessed that he's
being gazed into and then well the
reason he tears his room apart is
looking for the bug which probably isn't
even there it's in his mind
the godfather coda the death of like
four leon i had no desire to make a
second godfather i had no desire to make
a third godfather i thought the first
one was sufficient but sometimes you are
swimming in a sea where there are needs
that you have to do like feed your
family which you have to figure out how
to negotiate my feeling about the third
movie
was that it was a coda
in music if you have a big piece of
music and you have a coda that's the
summing up the epilogue both mario and i
had agreed that the script would be a
coda and it would be called the death of
michael corleone now of course by that
time the studio was much more interested
in calling it the godfather part three
because that could imply there being a
part four and a part five and a part six
which really it's not in that material
but you can make anything be in any
material at the time it came out it came
out on christmas so it was came out in a
pretty fast post-production period we
weren't really finished but it came out
and it was and they wanted to be called
the godfather part three and i didn't
have the power that i had had during
part two but i subsequently took a look
at it and said well if i could do it the
way i wanted and what mario and i had
agreed i would call it the death of
michael corleone and it would not be
considered a third
installment but rather it would be
considered the third
resolution that would try to resolve the
entire two first two movies
with a with a coda or an epilogue
[Music]
and so that's when i had the opportunity
paramount graciously gave me the chance
to do what i wanted
and so i took the film and i re re-cut
it and made it a little shorter in fact
and began in a different place and did
it in a different place and then moved
things around in a version that i
thought was very superior to what had
come out as godfather part three and so
that's what is now going to come out on
the 50th anniversary it does the job
that i had hoped and that mario had
hoped to do you know mario
that collaboration turned out to be like
having a wonderful uncle
mario puzzo he was a real character and
we developed a nice working relationship
and i'm very fond of him and his memory
[Music]
megalopolis
you know usually my projects are made in
leapfrog fashion what that means is that
i'll be writing
the rain people and i write and i write
and then there comes a point where you
have this enzyme secreted which makes
you hate what you're writing and then
you eventually abandon it you say i hate
it i it's no good then you start another
one
and the same thing happens you work on
it work on it and then after a while you
start to hate it then you abandon it and
you look at the other one that you had
abandoned you know that wasn't so bad
and then you take it and you make it so
you're always making
the one that you had just abandoned
and indeed i was working on megalopolis
which was going to be my
i figure i'm getting old now and i've
made movies in every style known to man
i've made movies in this style and that
style has that i've learned also now i
would like to find out what is my style
and i'm just going to slowly pick a
subject matter that interests me and
then to write an original screenplay
from that and i did i always took notes
and i read a lot of stuff and i became
interested in a peculiar
little wrinkle in roman history which is
known as the catalan conspiracy the
catalan conspiracy really was a story of
someone
whose position was very classical and
old
that the old traditions are good
which is so you know versus a conflict
with someone who was a more futuristic
that we should leap over the old and
into new ideas and i thought wouldn't it
be interesting if you made a roman epic
but didn't set it in ancient rome said
it in modern new york did a story a big
new york story
in which cataline and a cicero or the
mayor and an architect were at odds
and what if
there was a girl what if it was the
daughter of the mayor who came to be in
love with the
opponent of the mayor so it could be a
lie i really wanted to make a love story
so i pieced together this sort of
piece that would be a love story which i
wanted to make so bad really
heartbreaking moving love story but also
a story of the debate between those who
believe that the way to go is to leap
into the future and those
who believe we should
secure the security of the past and and
i thought that would be something that i
didn't know the answer to
but it would sure
be worth working on and if i might come
to a position where i knew an answer for
that question learning from the great
ilya kazan i always try to have a word
that is the core of what the movie is
really about in one word for godfather
the key word is succession
that's what the movie is about
apocalypse now morality the conversation
privacy
megalopolis
you know what it is
sincerity
that's the word i use when i say what
what should i do
you know okay it's a future city what is
it like well for sure it has to be
something that we all want to live in
if we come away like los angeles
it's a little creepy it all looks like a
monastery or something
that's not going to work i think it
could be for a lot of people saying that
we're really excited for megalopolis too
well i'm going to start i'm starting now
i'm working on it now in fact